voters in Florida will also decide
important races for Senator and Governor
but that campaign is also about
something bigger highlighted by dueling
rallies yesterday held by former
president Trump and Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis Tony is in Miami this morning
covering the campaign in his native
state hey Tony can you try to paint the
picture of what's going on in Florida
for us
being here over Biscayne Bay Nate good
to see you good morning Gail and John as
well into our viewers at home uh you
know we've been talking about the states
that could determine control of Congress
and Florida is on that list it's not
that it's not Marco Rubio the senator
here is still battling with Val demings
a congresswoman but the conversation is
also about the White House dueling
rallies you mentioned yesterday former
president Donald Trump and sitting
governor of Florida Ron DeSantis could
be a preview not of 2022 and the big
themes here but of 2024.
[Applause]
in the final hours before election day
we found our spot in the Press pen it's
great to be here in my home state of
Florida and watched as thousands of
Florida Republicans cheered and chanted
for a man not even on the ballot this
year we are going to take back that big
beautiful magnificent White House Donald
Trump's closing argument for Senator
Marco Rubio sounded at times like an
opening statement for himself under the
Trump Administration we had the greatest
economy in the history of the world with
no inflation ahead of another possible
Run for the White House in 2024
something he's been teasing now for
weeks I will very very very probably do
it again okay and on Saturday the former
president pushed into new territory
touting his poll numbers within the
party and trying out a nickname for
perhaps his biggest potential rival in
24. Rhonda sanctimonious at 10 that's
Florida Governor Rhonda santis he's
talking about someone who has not ruled
out a White House run of his own and who
on Sunday while fellow Florida
Republicans joined Donald Trump in Miami
was on the other side of the state
speaking to a large crowd of his own
free state of Florida
[Applause]
worry about 2024 though he needs to win
re-election over former Governor Charlie
Christ
how do you think the race is going so
far I think it's going well uh you know
it's a tough race let's be honest recent
polls show him trailing DeSantis by
double digits and Chris like much of the
country sees this race as a Bellwether
so if Charlie Crist loses on Tuesday
what does that say about the direction
of America well I think it would say
about the direction of America is awful
back at the Trump rally in Miami voters
were already looking ahead
[Applause]
we spotted clemin Connolly in a homemade
Ron DeSantis top gov jacket but with
Trump paraphernalia along the sleeves we
wondered how she might decide between
the two your message to Rhonda Santos if
he's watching is that Governor because I
love you as Governor I love him as
Governor that's about how Denise ebers
feels as well can you imagine yourself
voting for Ron DeSantis I could
but right now I think Donald Trump's our
ticket but if Trump doesn't run then to
Santos then DeSantis is your guy
absolutely but not everyone is a trump
first Republican I don't think the
census has a less baggage I know a lot
of people who say Trump the the
impeachment failed there's no baggage
which may be why Donald Trump is
campaigning here at all come rain let's
stay out here right I'm not living or
Ron DeSantis this might be the Great the
greatest rally we
've
been
former president Donald Trump they're
doing maybe his best Drew Barrymore in
the rain impersonation uh and by the way
it's not just Ron DeSantis that the
former president might have to worry
about there's Mike Pompeo there's Mike
Pence there's other Governors who might
run as for DeSantis for his part uh
allies of his texted with our Bob Costa
after that comment in Pennsylvania from
Donald Trump and said he is on deterred
they are still advising uh the governor
here in Florida to go for it and I have
to say guys if you think I'm crazy to
talk about 2024 when the votes have not
even been cast in 2022 I'll leave you
with some simple math there are fewer
days between right now and the first
presidential primary in 2024 looking
ahead than there are between here and
the presidential inauguration of Joe
Biden looking back so it's going to be a
long night tomorrow get some sleep
tonight but it's going to be a short two
years from where we're standing to 2024.
he's spot on
you're spot on Tony also justifying why
he wants to go hang out in the sunshine
in Florida I'm taking the look Tony it
looks good man open color
for me but he's exactly right the
narrative for the next presidential
campaign gets started on Tuesday thank
you Tony